welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and moon knight is a new marvel
series starring oscar isaac as mark
spector who becomes the vigilante of
moon knight after possession by an
egyptian moon deity named konchu who
leaves them with powers that haunt him
in the form of what might look like
dissociative identity disorder i am so
pumped for this series and for oscar
isaac to crush it in a nerd franchise
that doesn't piss off half of its
viewers every installment or force them
to do like ivan ooze cosplay as
apocalypse and x-men we got some new
trailer footage for the series on disney
plus so i'm gonna react to it give you
my first thoughts and then since i got a
lot of big news to cover today from the
disney plus day announcements my frame
by frame breakdown of all the little
details he missed in this will come out
tomorrow but on to the reaction here we
go
[Music]
whoa the reflection's different
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
whoa
the voice
in your head
what
it devours you
whoa
oh the tone of this looks so cool
what
there's more
oh my god there's so much going on
what
let's get to work everyone's dancing
everyone's falling to their deaths and
i'm about to paint okay so i'm super
pumped for moon knight the type of point
of view shots that we're getting of
oscar isaac reminds me a lot of what we
saw in one division a character not
really sure of their reality which is
perfect for a character like mark
spector who is really kind of a
vigilante in the marvel comics with lots
of different identities like you have
his wealthy elite personality stephen
grant as well as his taxi driver jake
lockley he himself is mark spector who
was kind of a mercenary who ended up
going through some egyptian runes and
ran into the egyptian moon deity of
konshu who gives him powers that are
associated with the cycles of the moon
but in later comics they depict all this
as a kind of exploration of dissociative
identity disorder so that's why in this
footage you see oscar isaac going in and
out of consciousness as he wakes up from
this reality not really sure of what his
moon knight identity was doing the night
before it looks like part of that
possession from konchu might happen in a
kind of museum it sounds like we hear a
few different voices in this like some
it's just gonna be oscar isaac's
traditional voice but it sounds like
he's completely changing his vocal
structure to play the different
identities i can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams it
devours you now if your holiday shopping
list includes some fellow nerdy
travelers you need to swing by our merch
partners at epic hero shop right now
this month they are opening the vault to
do limited re-releases of some of their
most popular shirt designs including the
loki gator polo shirt the shirt that
broke the internet this will be the new
and improved loki gator mark ii and it's
going to be awesome they're also
bringing back some of our favorite
latest obsession shirts and they're
going to have a huge 15 off cyber week
sale from november 21st to the 29th sign
up for their newsletter at the bottom of
their website to get notified about the
latest drops they have a variety of
shirts hoodies stickers and other merch
inspired by all of your favorite
properties like loki spider-man and two
new shirts inspired by eternals there's
also official new rockstars merch with
our logo so you can wrap our channel at
the grocery store and get a thumbs up
from the produce department guy that's
what i that's what that's that aka me
when i'm when i'm moonlighting there and
things are fine it's fine i'm fine check
it all out at epicheroshop.com
be your own hero now part of what makes
moon knight so iconic is he has this
kind of pale white color tone reflecting
the moody glow of the moon itself which
even in a super dark room they're still
able to evoke that kind of pale glow
yeah based off the character that oscar
isaac seems to be playing he's less of
like a badass mercenary looks more like
a nerd or a thief a scavenger type who
might be stealing some relics that he
should not be stealing and that's what
ends up causing the possession now we
know this series is going to be six
episodes of course starring oscar isaac
as mark spector but we also know ethan
hawke is going to be in this series as
an unknown villain actress mae callum
away in an unroll and then also gaspard
uliel who we believe is midnight man aka
anton mogart midnight man is known as a
villain to moon knight in the comics now
one big question we have about moon
knight coming into the mcu is he is a
character linked with the supernatural
in the occult and a big spoiler warning
for eternals if you haven't seen it yet
but of course the second post-credits
scene features dane whitman discovering
his family sword of the ebony blade the
weapon of the black knight lineage and
he hears a voice from behind him asking
are you sure you're ready for that mr
whitman that of course being the voice
of mahershala ali as blade suggesting a
probable team up between these two but
it also makes us wonder are we going to
see a team up with all of these
supernatural warriors including moon
knight as part of marvel's rumored plans
for a midnight sun series with all these
guys hearing mystical voices from the
shadows fighting these supernatural
threats something that could tie in with
this new agatha house of harkness series
i am so pumped to go through this
footage frame by frame because i know
there are a ton of cool visual details
things that we all missed so be sure to
check out the breakdown of this footage
coming to the channel as soon as i can
get it to you as well as attempts to
explain all the big news we got from
disney plus day be sure to check out our
merch store at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you